i'm sorry i can't i can't i can't i
can't i can i can
i can't i can no i can't i really can't
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by billy eilish
you know from platinum hits singles like
ocean eyes and lovely fun fact she's the
youngest guest in hot ones history
and her first studio album when we all
fall asleep where do we go is set to
drop march 29th
followed by a worldwide tour billy
welcome to the show
thank you how are you good how are you
a little nervous mm-hmm i know that you
like the taki chip so i take
your comfortable around spicy food i
love spicy food
but if i don't know well let's push it
to the limit today billy you ready
hold on invisalign coming out
okay that's how you know she means
business
[Music]
[Applause]
so as your fans know the billy eilish
origin story begins at home with you and
your brother phineas writing
and recording songs in a makeshift
studio in his room
what's the last sibling argument you've
had over a creative decision
we have those like every day i imagine
yeah somebody has to win always it's
like one or the other
i feel like there's so much like let's
decide let's just get something we're
all happy with
no oh [ __ ] that like one of us
is right he's literally right there but
you know is that how it works
yeah and then can you draw back the
curtain on what it's like to go to a
talent show for homeschooled kids like
what was the greatest act you've ever
seen and then what was the biggest like
what the f is going on here moment
well what was really lame was that the
parents
would let the kids sing like full length
songs
that sucked because we had to sit
through
some [ __ ] like i remember somebody sang
some taylor swift song and every time
she would mess up she would stomp
like really hard and like scream she'd
be like [ __ ]
like every oh my god it was insane and
it went on and on
like on and on and uh for my first song
i sang um
happiness is a warm gun when i was like
nine
but i mean it's true but [ __ ] those were
homeschoolers are
[ __ ] crazy
[Music]
hippy dippy green not bad
not bad so i can tell by some of the
oddball
shows that you've appeared on hot ones
included that you were very much raised
by the internet when you were on
teens react you said that you'd seen
like every episode when you were 12
years old
do you remember when you discovered
youtube and the things that you were
drawn to early on
it was like the classics because you
know how it used to be like
things were viral now it's not no
nothing is like viral it's just like
everything is you know i don't know it
was like chocolate rain and like
the one where the like rapist went into
the window and then they made it into a
song
you know what i'm talking about hide
your uh hide your kids hide your wife
and hide your husband
yeah it's funny i remember watching that
a million times
did your dream of one day working at
target have anything to do
with the alex from target meme dude you
know what's so
stupid that when that meme happened uh
there was this like there was a like one
of the first like meme accounts that was
like a meme account
made a hoodie that said lol you're not
target
no no lol you're not alex from target
and i bought one
and it was like 200 whoa
and i bought it and then i took a
picture in it
and i posted it and i remember it got
like 300 likes and i thought
i was famous you made it i thought i was
famous i literally thought it was famous
[Music]
you taking big bites over there sir how
the [ __ ] are you
so i know that you're a proud la native
you rep highland park neighborhood
that's known for its artistic
sensibilities
and before we move on with the wing i
want to bust out the laptop
because we have a very special message
for you from another highland park
legend
what the hell is that supposed to mean
[Music]
hi billy this is john niece from galco's
soda pop stop in highland park los
angeles
your favorite soda store
i hope you're having fun on the hot ones
i understand they have some
really tasty independent sodas for you
to try
good luck and have a good time
so this is a segment that we call pop
stars where we're gonna put your palette
to the test
and give you some regional sodas to see
if you can identify them
by the taste get the flavor right that's
points you can name the brand that's
bonus
what can you tell the people about
galcos you know it was like it was such
a treat it was just like let's go to the
sodapop stop we go
there's like a candy section we'd get
the nickel nips
which are like it's like a little
package of these like
like miniature sodas and they're all
different colors they're just made out
of wax
and you bite off the top and you just
suck out this juice
but they're a fire though and i used to
chew
on i used to chew on the wax
galco memories yaakov memories okay
where should i start
probably one okay now i'm gonna start at
three okay
not a bad [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] ginger something it's not ginger
ale but it's
you know you're you know your sodas [ __ ]
it literally says [ __ ] and bull
oh [ __ ] and bowl and it's a ginger soda
bowl so ding ding ding ding we're going
to tune
number two number two
[Music]
that is the common reaction to that one
that is a common reaction to that one
is that that is moxie moxie
anus it tastes like an anus so it's the
anus pop that's
two for two and then one more billy this
better be the one i want it to be
[Music]
grape soda that's what it is for sure
here wait whoo is this soy milk it is
okay
whoa it's gonna be such a pretty color
wait
it looks like taro
it does it's not it's better though with
the soy milk it's better
oh i see a little flake i love that
pepper flake
[Music]
does that mean you like it i kind of
like that one
so know that tyler the creator and
childish gambino are two artists that in
the pantheon you look up to not
just because of their music ability but
also the way that they become fully
formed creatives who can
write for tv design do festival
curations so what i want to do is bounce
a few potential
billy eilish extracurriculars off you
and i'm just curious where you'd take
them
what would a billy eilish horror movie
look like
probably the barrier friend video i
don't know if any of you've seen it
came out a couple days ago it would be
in the realm of that
everybody thinks i sold my soul to the
illuminati i don't really know what the
illuminati is to be honest with you
that's what somebody would say if they
sold their soul to the illuminati
would you ever want to design a video
game yeah that'd be so
sick oh my god see i used to play like
not really the classics i kind of i
would play like i used to play elo milo
a lot
i loved elo milo that was like my
favorite game in the world
uh do you know what that game is no it's
this game
where it's these two little boo boos
they're these little
they're so cute they're these little
creatures one is named elo and the other
side
milo it's this sort of anti-gravity
world
where there's all these little blocks
and they start apart from each other
and the idea is you just get to each
other and then when they get to each
other they just
hug and they do this little dance and
that's the whole game there's no prize
you just get to each other so the whole
idea is the game is just like losing the
person you love and then finding them
again it's so
cute and uh i used to play red dead
redemption
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hard but i only
played it to ride the horses
well calientes i'm doing good
you're doing so good i feel [ __ ]
did you speak too soon no
all right billy we have a current
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context
so i'll bust out the laptop i'll show
you the picture you just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good
all right billy
you are hanging out with takashi
murakami it's all insane did you guys
talk about anime and sneakers uh-huh
literally but he doesn't really speak
english and i don't speak japanese so
there's a lot of like
nonverbal communication yeah but he he
is like one of the most humble
pieces of art i've ever seen in my life
he he walks around barefoot
with his little dog palm yep i went to
this like other studio i feel like i'm
going to faint i went to this other
studio careful around your eyes
making me nervous with you know the hot
spots
okay um i was
we went to this other studio which was
like a motion capture studio
and they put me in like a full body
like tight full body motion capturing
outfit so it was like i was like up in
there up in that [ __ ] kim kardashian
filmed me like with like the tight like
almost like leather like whatever it was
and then they put these little balls all
over me like little white balls
stuck them to me and on the screen
was like an anime like an anime just
like walking around and i was like
that's so sick because this [ __ ] was
like slim thick and stuff like she was
just like on the wall just like
and but they that was like you from the
i didn't know what it was
um it was just like this anime doll that
looked bomb
and then i lifted my arm up and she
lifted her arm up and that was
[ __ ] crazy and then it all connected
it all connected sense
and then i just did the whole thing and
it was like automatically copying what i
was doing with the anime
doll thing on it was crazy that's sick
it was crazy
do you have a favorite memory from the
second annual brockhampton prom night
um i forgot the whole bridge in copykat
the whole thing and the audience hated
it
that's all i remember audience hated it
but they're dope though every single one
of them
sweethearts like just the nicest dudes
shout out brockhampton shout out
brockhampton
i'm not gonna drink water anymore i've
decided well let's see if you stick with
that
how do you do this stuff week in and
week out
it's just you know don't you feel that
way sometimes too though when you're
like
oh it's a full press day then i've got
this tour and then this yeah and i hate
it though and then you're like
do you enjoy this yeah any job
turns into a job especially when you're
eating spicy ass chicken wings every
week
for the internet's amusement you must
experience that i do
all the time i mean it's like it's a lot
of bad [ __ ] but it's also a lot of good
[ __ ] that you can't get without the
magic
and you wouldn't trade it you know like
there's nothing else i want
right c would you go back you know like
how much would you have to get paid to
go back
and have to go through it all again but
then i wouldn't trade with anyone for
where i am
[Music]
agreed yeah i get that
i get an existential conversation about
heaven over yeah
gluten-free nugs over here so many
artists obsess
about the idea of being misunderstood or
having words mangled but you seem to
almost
invite it i mean this is why i'm okay
with people thinking i've been
sold to the illuminati or whatever
because it's like
art is up for interp it should be up for
interpretation i don't
i don't want to see somebody say this is
my theory about what the song is about
and then have a whole thing and me be
like that's not what it's about i think
that's so
boring one of my favorite parts about
making music is that
people take it in the way that they take
it and i have no control over that
it's so hard to form a sentence right
now
but yeah like everything's up for
interpretation
[Music]
it's a heart
[Applause]
put it in rotation
okay keep asking me things so it
wouldn't be a hot ones interview unless
we took a wing to obsess on food
preferences
do you remember what you were eating
when you tweeted food is such a powerful
little hoe
one she could take control of anyone
i think i was eating taco bell
it was either taco bell or
a burrito from my house where does
creating the
billy ache donut for donut friend rank
in your list of career accomplishments
it's a big one i got boobs on my shirt
by the way
it's
damn it this is really burning my lips
up here
in an interview with vanity fair you
said that the only time that you don't
get recognized is when you're in trader
joe's you know what
it's not safe i was gonna say do you
feel a freedom when you're walking the
aisles at tj's or not so much
not anymore anymore not even costco
i went to costco on my birthday because
i'm just i'm doing this for my lips
because my lips are very
um spiced out it happens
and i don't want to lick them [ __ ]
can i just dip my lips in this hold on
you know you're the one who made the
water wool you can break it
i'm not the vegan nugget police over
here i'm not breaking it though
because you're not just dipping my water
i mean dipping my lips
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
instant
[Music]
yeah i don't believe he's good
no all right billy well it's clear
sitting across from you
the drip it's a sight to behold but your
fans know
that you're more likely to be elbow deep
in a bargain bin than buying out the
gucci store
how do you distinguish between a steel
and a rip-off when it comes to vintage
designer gear
i can't do this this is really crazy
it's crazy it's crazy
i'm sorry i can't i can't i can't i
can't i can i can
i can't i can't no i can't i really
can't can we get some director's
commentary from some of our favorite
billy eilish fit pics up first what can
you tell us about this picture of soulja
boy
hold on take a lap billy
take a lap walk it out
i don't really run otherwise i wouldn't
be able to tell
so big draco okay yep
oh my god billy are you okay
[Music]
there's two more yeah you're telling me
who wore it better you were guy fieti
me i should help him and then lastly
what can you tell me about this look
so uh
i know billy i know so
i was in chicago not here but a week
before this
when i was at lollapalooza
i was wearing a beanie that day okay
then i was told
that somebody saw a security guard
throw it into the crowd my beanie who
does that
it's my bidding right i was pissed off
at this plant
and i was screaming and i was really
angry
and i was with young blood you know that
is mm-hmm tons of like bad [ __ ]
did i just hit you with the water i i
ducked it like okay tricks
okay god why am i telling the story
then i got up does it all relate to this
yeah it does no it does and then i got
up and i was jumping around and i was
like
i want my [ __ ] beanie and i was like
complaining like that literally like
annoying and i jumped
one time literally like this
like that fell over
sprained my ankle suddenly i'm alone in
this big ass room jaden smith
comes down with a big-ass cuban chain
around cuban link around his neck
okay he put his hands over my foot
and was like i'm healing you
vandy the pink who is like a
bootleg sort of designer made this boot
for me
because he heard that my ankle was
sprained you like that i told a whole
story
i loved what they even asked for oh
ice coming in thank you
i put hot sauce on her titties
[Music]
uh
so every huge star has their online
protection
task force whether it's the rihanna navy
or ariana grande fans have you
ever used the billy eilish twitter army
for
evil they do i mean i don't even have to
say anything they do it on their own
they really do it on their own obviously
i go on it because they get instinct but
i don't say anything i feel i don't
share anything with the internet
i've heard you say that you love being
judged do you think that it's important
to listen to your haters
not to listen but to to find humor in it
i used to be like i love hate
it's like the junior mints and it's like
the it's like yes
the chips you gotta be careful when you
ask you gotta be careful
i don't know man
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra
on the last vegan nugget you don't have
to
if you don't want to you don't have to
if you don't want to billy
i don't have a show tonight billy eilish
coming on strong
oh my god is that a lot that's good
that's good that's textbook
[Music]
do you have fun no cheers billy
[Music]
oh okay
i'm gonna do this one then again because
i'm gonna do it
okay
[Music]
i'm here look it
chewing off the bomb just for added
i'm in awe billy i thought your back was
against the ropes
it was i thought that's all it could be
and now look at you
going back down the line hungry for more
and here we are at the end of our meal
and just one more obstacle
before we get you out of here billy
eilish you once said
that smiling makes you feel weak and
small and as a disaffected emotionless
host
i could not agree with you more so
now that our mouths are on fire brain's
burning
can you describe what's going on in your
body using
only a resting [ __ ] face and i will do
this oh my god
you don't even have to say it because i
can see it billy eyelash and look at you
10 wings up 10 wings down and even going
back for seconds
when you'd run the gauntlet and now
there's nothing left to do
but salute you billy eilish this camera
this camera or this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
what does that mean if you have any
plugs you want to
hit my album comes on march 29th when we
all fall asleep where do we go
i go to hell when i die
so what is he
good job billy good job
[Applause]
god what the [ __ ] it's it's a wild it's
a wild show oh my god
i know how you feeling okay oh my god
billy great job though great job
committing to it
this is so insane have you ever had
anything that hot
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and have a very exciting hot sauce news
update
if you sign up for the monthly
subscription box in march
you'll get boom a bottle of the classic
boom a bottle of los calientes
and double boom the elusive scorpion
edition of the last dab
is back in stock and available first to
hot ones monthly subscription box
subscribers
and this is the best part we're slashing
prices everything must go
instead of the usual forty dollars
thirty dollars for this
all-star trio of hot ones hot sauces
heatness.com for all your hot ones hot
sauce needs
who appreciates you baby i do